bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week end votre magazine dédié à vos
sorties et vos loisirs
au sommaire de ce numéro un week-end
sportif avec le palais des sports de
plaisir qui accueille le temps d'un week
end les demi-finales de temps ligne
bâton disciplines sportives mêlant
gymnastique et de danse et maniement
d'un bâton pour la deuxième année
consécutive les enfants pourront
s'essayer au mode des kills un parcours
sportif composé d'obstacles et de course
et pour ceux qui seraient tentés par des
activités nautiques à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines propose ce
week end une nouvelle activité le paddle
vous pourrez tester votre équilibre avec
ce sport de glisse pour parler d'eux ces
rendez-vous du week-end en plateau jean
baptiste dupont vice-président de la
ligue ile de france de twirling bâton en
charge de l'organisation de l'épreuve
pascal quatre hommes directeur du mud
des et mickaël chavardes s éducateur
sportif de l'école de voile de l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
bonjour monsieur
on va commencer avec le thé en ligne
bâton pendant deux jours je le disais le
public du palais des sports de plaisir
va pouvoir découvrir cette discipline
ce sont les demi-finales nord-est et
nord-ouest et s'est organisée par la
ligue ile de france jean baptiste dupont
le temps d'une bâton est une épreuve qui
mêle plusieurs disciplines mais bien oui
bonjour le twirling bâton c'est à la
fois de la danse la gymnastique et puis
le maniement de bâton
donc c'est un sport qui est encore très
peu connue qui se pratique simplement en
gymnase et donc
les demi finales du championnat de
france ce week-end à plaisir au palais
des sports donc la moitié de la france
c'est le quart nord est et est sud
on va dire plutôt puisque l'ouest c'est
de l'autre côté ça fera en bretagne donc
ça va réunir à peu près entre 250 et 300
athlètes
donc on attend à peu près entre 1200 et
1500 spectateurs sur le week end
c'est peu connu mais ça vient dr ligue
bâton commencer par yves ans c'est
arrivé en france dans les années 70 par
un monsieur monsieur bell qui a ramené
un bâton à sa fille et tout aidé tout a
démarré un petit peu de là puisque en
même temps parallèle il y avait un petit
peu la fédération française de
majorettes et donc ça ça n'a rien à voir
mais c'est un peu le parallèle c'est à
dire que partir de là la discipline ne
turing bâton s'est développé dans
certains clubs où il existait déjà un
petit peu le maniement du bâton savait
pas ce les majorettes c'est vraiment il
ya le maniement du bâton toute la
dextérité mais il ya toute la gym
derrière la prouesse technique aussi
comme j'ai pu vous les expliquer la
difficulté dans le twirling bâton
aujourd'hui quand j'ai dit à la
discipline la danse et la gym la
gymnastique on sait très bien que la
gymnastique au sol aujourd'hui les
athlètes pratiquent la gymnastique sur
un tapis ce qu'on appelle un praticable
de gym aujourd'hui un pote on regarde
les athlètes chez nous il évolue avec le
sol du gymnase ya pas de tapis à rien
donc exécuter une souplesse ou un lancer
ou un coastal font les mains et
rattraper le bâton c'est extrêmement
compliqué difficile
vous désirez ya plus de 200 participants
des filles et garçons de tous les âges
oui absolument part du plus petit c'est
à dire on va dire les benjamines
jusqu'aux seniors donc on a toutes les
catégories en solo en duo en équipe donc
les solistes 20 ses seuls les duos a
peut être garçons filles ou fils ou
éventuellement que le garçon il y en a
très peu et puis les équipes donc on a
des équipes de 6 à 8 des groupes de 10 à
15 20 donc en plus de la difficulté
technique et aussi toute la coordination
quand on est 15 avant ça doit être un
gros travail de préparation mais parce
qu'il faut être rigoureux
les ensembles le jury note effectivement
à ce que tout le monde évolue en même
temps ensemble
pas de chute les échanges donc c'est
compliqué plus il ya d'athlètes plus on
multiplie les risques de chute
donc oui c'est très spectaculaire c'est
une discipline
a voir absolument on parle de données de
demi finale donc c'est un rendez vous
important pour les athlètes
ben oui parce que là on a on va voir la
moitié de la forme en s'emportant de
marseille en allant jusqu'à lille on a
tous les tous les jeunes qui ont
pratiqué depuis le début de la saison
les championnats départementaux les
régionaux le quart de finale donc là
c'est les meilleurs qui reste on arrive
déjà à un niveau mais c'est de la
nationale 2 c'est ça oui c'est on va
dire le niveau intermédiaire entre les
débutants et puis tout ce qui est
nationale 1 élite peu comparé au
football au basket
les différents niveaux techniques je
disais tout à l'heure c'est un sport
encore assez peu connu et pourtant on
trouve 12 clubs dans les événements dont
certains sont sur 50 ans ont nivelé
oui absolument il ya un club à montigny
y en a un plaisir il y en a un mot repas
y en a 1 trappe dans la circonscription
il ya pas mal de clubs il ya douze clubs
dans les yvelines et le département des
yvelines est un des deux premiers
départements en france avec le
département de l'isère
on a 600 licences et pour ce week-end
ceux qui voudraient venir ça déplacé
qu'est ce qui va se passer ce sont
toutes les épreuves
on va pouvoir regarder alors samedi
essentiellement toutes les catégories
soliste avec des duos et puis dimanche
on enchaînera avec le restant des
catégories
duo plus tout ce qui est équipé groupe
donc effectivement il ya la possibilité
de venir voir la compétition au palais
des sports de plaisir pierre de
coubertin effectivement l'entrée est
payante avec un tarif préférentiel pour
les licenciés et un autre tarif pour les
non licenciés et les gens qui seraient
tentés de venir sur le week-end et un
tarif week end voila voila c'est sur ces
mots qu'on va on va conclure sans le
temps loubaton merci jean baptiste
dupont
si vous souhaitez assister aux prouesses
techniques et artistiques détruire leur
direction le palais des sports pierre de
coubertin de plaisir samedi 7 et
dimanche 8 mai jusqu'au 25 juillet le
musée national de port royal des champs
rend hommage à rosa bonheur la célèbre
peintre animalière du 19e siècle
trois générations d'artistes ont pu
développer leur art dans l'atelier
maniwaki a été acquis en 1865 par le
frère auguste et qui est maintenant la
maison des bonheurs et une annexe de la
mairie
l'exposition est exceptionnel en france
la plupart des oeuvres de rosa bonheur
étant conservés à londres où m et au
metropolitan de new york
un sujet de sephora namani et camille
lambert hommage à rosa bonheur et sa
famille durant plus de 50 ans ou dix
neuvième siècle
trois générations d'artistes dans la
famille ont développé leur art de la
peinture animalière à la musique dans la
maison des bonheurs de magny les hameaux
acquises en 1865 pour y installer un
atelier devenu aujourd'hui annexe de la
mairie
le musée de port royal des champs leur
consacre une exposition jusqu'au 25
juillet cette famille dans son ensemble
a à plusieurs talents et donc l'idée
c'est de confronter ces différents
médiums artistiques de voir comment ces
différents médiums artistiques
finalement créer un art à partir d'
inspiration commune ce monde animalier
qui l'ont vraiment cherché à explorer
sous toutes ses formes 70 peintures et
sculptures sont exposées certaines de la
célèbre peintre animalière rosa bonheur
souvent comparée de son temps à jacques
raymond aubrac à ça d'autres de son père
raymond de son frère auguste et les
sculptures de son frère isidore un art
familiale tournée vers la nature et le
monde animé
lié avec une sensibilité pour le monde
des pâturages et de la forêt un héritage
du père de rosa bonheur proche de la
peinture romantique
ce qui est très intéressant chez eux
c'est que il y a eu un véritable intérêt
pour les spécificités des animaux il ya
vraiment la volonté de s'intéresser très
spécifiquement à la à l'anatomie des
animaux et avec ce côté un peu
positiviste du 19e siècle
si vous voulez et par ailleurs ils ont
pu participé à l'illustration des
ouvrages
scientifique agricole cette exposition
est une première en france
la majorité des oeuvres de rosa bonheur
se trouvant à londres où metropolitan à
new york pour la réaliser le musée de
port royal a bénéficié de prêts du musée
des beaux-arts de bordeaux du musée de
fontainebleau et de différentes
collections privées
depuis jeudi et des valeureux testent
leurs compétences et leurs limites
physiques dans la boue lors du mode d
depuis l'an dernier le parcours du
combattant s'adapte aussi aux plus
jeunes avec le mode des kids fatale
pascal quatre ans que vous êtes le
directeur du monde et je disais tout à
l'heure mais pourquoi avoir adapté le
concept aux plus jeunes sous la pression
des parents nombreux parents nous
demander à ce que leurs enfants puissent
salir dans la boue choses à discuter
donc on a exaucé leurs voeux depuis
l'année dernière les modes kid peuvent
évoluer le sih dans la boue et ça se
passe comme les adultes y a pas que la
boue alors on a adapté bien sûr le
parcours aux enfants donc c'est un
parcours de 500 mètres qui vont pouvoir
faire plusieurs fois il y aura certes
isaac semble énormément à ceux des
grands et bien sûr tout en sécurité et
tout en amusant - ils pourront refaire
plusieurs fois mais peut-être qu'un
aimant faudra et stopper les enfants et
n'arrivent pas toujours à se contrôler
mais oui alors il ya les parents qui
seront là nous qui pouvons les arrêter
quand ils veulent nous on les laisse
s'amuser ils vont pouvoir courir pendant
20 minutes en fonction de leur âge et
ils auront tous une médaille à la fin et
plein de petits cadeaux ils sont
encadrés quand même ya peut-être un
petit échauffement au début pour éviter
de les lâcher comme ça oui un
entraînement comme les adultes un petit
peu guerrier où on leur fait on les fait
crier les parents aussi ont droit de
s'échauffer avec eux les parents vont
les suivre sur le parcours ils vont
courir à côté ils vont prendre des
photos ils ont les encourager il ya
beaucoup de public aussi qui vient
nombreux pour les encourager et donc
voilà c'est un petit peu le moment star
des enfants quels types d'obstacles ils
vont devoir franchir en paix grimper
sauter tout à fait aux âmes un petit peu
tous cités ils vont bien sûr ramper dans
des tuyaux avec de la boue intérieur
ils vont voir franchir une palissade
ils vont devoir porter des petits sacs
de gravier bien sûr pas trop lourd en
pot sans de leur âge voilà un petit peu
comme un petit peu comme les grands
finalement vous appuyez sur l'âge il ya
quand même peut-être des limites
oui il ya passé pour les enfants de 7 à
11 ans finalement les enfants qui sont
nés entre 2004 et 2009 faut avoir une
certaine condition physique peut-être
quand même nom pour les adultes oui il
en faut une certaine mais pour les
enfants non n'importe quel enfant on
peut prendre du plaisir encore une fois
ya pas de limite de temps il pourra
prendre le temps qu'il veut pour pour
s'amuser et prendre du plaisir des
enfants doivent être accompagnés des
parents mais sur le terrain comment ça
se passe les parents les suées vous il
ya quand même des animateurs qui sont là
pour aider pour un oui oui un gros staff
y ait une trentaine de personnes qui
encadrent ces vagues de 40 à 50 enfants
mais on peut pas empêcher les parents de
courir à côté de les prendre en photos
et de les suivre et encore une fois
comme sa peine compétition que tout le
monde est là pour s'amuser
les parents peuvent courir à côté vous
parlez de vagues c'est comme les adultes
s'il ya des départs différés quand même
pour éviter que tout le monde soit sur
le terrain ou même moment tout à fait
pour que le passage d'obstacles se fasse
dans les meilleurs sites dans l'avenir
si on était possible soit très fluide il
ya des vagues toutes les 20 minutes de
50 enfants qui partent pour les adultes
ces quatre cents 400 adultes qui partent
à toutes les 20 minutes pour les enfants
c'est 50 c'est en ont restreint un petit
peu oui oui de t'avoir d'avoir un
minimum de risques s'ils sont trop
nombreux et peuvent ils peuvent se
pousser sachant que les enfants dès cet
âge là cède les adultes s'entraînent et
sont obligés de s'entraîner mais me les
enfants cède c'est le début de la vie la
vie à obstacles il faut s'entraider
voilà on fait un rapprochement entre la
vie et la course à obstacles
il faut que dès cet âge ils apprennent
la solidarité et pour le coup les modes
d kidby fraude tout ça va ça c'est ça
aussi le mode et c'est dépassé le simple
la simple épreuve sportive c'est un
monde à l'image du combattant du
de la boue mais c'est ça aussi ça c'est
l'antre elle s'est développée ça c'est
chez les enfants dès leur plus jeune âge
oui oui elle a par exemple pour les
adultes on a 90 % des participants qui
vient équipe de quatre vraiment pour
développer la solidarité pour dépasser
certes leurs capacités physiques mais
surtout mental voilà donc on essaye un
petit peu d'adopter sa pour les enfants
ils courent pas en équipe les cours de
manière individuelle
ils sont encore un petit peu très très
solitaire des enfants de cet âge là où
je suis ramzy réapprendre honte pour
passer pour franchir des obstacles dans
la vie on a besoin des dsk des
recommandations quand même peut-être
physique présenter un certificat médical
nouveau pour les adultes oui un
certificat médical depuis ya quand même
des des parties de natation un petit peu
importante donc il faut que avoir un
certificat médical d'aptitude à la
compétition pour les enfants non
uniquement la présence des enfants
encore une fois il ya aucun danger pour
les enfants
les deux mille 2000 jeunes qui ont
participé aux modèles et dernière il ya
eu aucun aucun souci et cette année on
attend 3000 on espère qu'il retient
soucis mais il ya très peu de risques
pour les enfants vraiment que de
l'amusement pour les plus jeunes qui
seraient intéressés on peut toujours
s'inscrire
oui alors les inscriptions sont
clôturées sur sur internet mais on peut
pas résister à la pression des parents
et des enfants qui viendront donc on
pourra prendre des inscriptions sur
place bien sûr et le premier départ
étant aux alentours de 10 heures il faut
arriver
quels sont les conseils au niveau des
horaires alors les premières vagues
toute façon son sont occupés les gens
qui sont pas encore inscrits je leur
conseille de venir vers 10h 11h
effectivement pour s'inscrire et pour
pouvoir partir vers 13h 14h voilà donc
faut venir vers 11h sur le quang binh
merci pascal 80 devenu en plateau le
mode des kids c'est juste du samedi 7
mai commence à 10h on disait rendez vous
au camp militaire de frileuse a même
entraîné équipé et surtout très motivés
on prend maintenant la direction du pavé
du canal à montigny le bretonneux comme
chaque semaine les libraires vous donne
une idée lecture pour ce week-end
laurent garin vous invite à lire le
chien est une personne de philippe
hofman on les écoute
alors bonjour pauline aujourd'hui j'ai
lu pour toi le chien est une personne de
philippe hofman qui est un psychologue
clinicien et qui nous explique là le
rôle et la position du chien dans une
famille et dans le cheminement bas de la
personne alors il passe en revue de
l'enfance donc de la naissance de
l'apparition du chien dans la famille
jusqu'à l'adolescence en passant toutes
les étapes le deuil et la construction
de l'homme et donc sa position du chien
qui n'est pas qu'un animal et qui aussi
qui fait partie car wallace est
prépondérant dans la famille
est ce que c'est un ouvrage accessible
où c'est vraiment un ouvrage de
psychologues cliniciens qui n'ont pas dû
annoncer un ouvrage très accessible qui
prend plein d'exemples concrets alors
qu'en fait chaque début de chapitre donc
qu'il fasse en revue comme ça dans la
vie des personnes chaque début de
chapitre c'est un exemple vraiment
concret où il cite voilà soit c'est un
petit bout avec qui découvrent l'arrivée
d'un chien dans sa famille soit c'est
une personne qui a eu un deuil et qui va
être accompagné par un chien soit c'est
un aveugle qui qui doit former son chien
enfin c'est donc que des petits exemples
concrets et ils discutent tout autour de
cet exemple c'est plutôt à destination
de gens qui ont déjà un chien ou ça peut
être accessible aux gens qui se posent
des questions justement sur alors la
relation de la maître du chien
je pense que ça peut être très utile
pour les personnes qui ont déjà un chien
voilà pour vraiment située à quoi à quoi
ça sert d'avoir un chien et pour les
personnes aussi qui veulent découvrir
l'animal mais pas que l'animal est
finalement de cette position du membre à
part entière dans la famille voilà du
côté de l'île des loisirs l'école de
voile propose dès ce week-end une
nouvelle activité du paddle une
discipline de glisse nautique voulait
créer ou l'équilibré a toute sa place
michael chavardes aise qu est ce que le
padel déjà le paddle c'est en français
c'est debout sur une planche tout
simplement d'onctueux debout sur une
planche et on payet donc on travaille l
équilibre entre on a la possibilité
d'être sur l'eau au calme et ça change
un peu du kayak
pourquoi proposer une telle activité ce
qu'on voit pas beaucoup c'est surtout la
mer en général le padel c'est un effet
de mode bien sûr on obligé de suivre le
mouvement
donc tout ce qui vient d'hawaï ces
précurseurs donc nous on s'adapte et on
propose et c'est aussi une demande de la
clientèle aux 10es fois un bon équilibre
c'est compliqué d'en faire ou la prise
en main quand même assez rapidement
c'est une prise en main très rapide au
bout de dix minutes on s'en sort très
bien
voilà c'est accessible à tout le monde
accessible à tout le monde sur les
enfants les adultes les enfants à partir
de 7 8 ans voilà après les adultes où il
faut être en forme physique quand même
juste peut-être une consigne faut je
pense c'est sur l'eau il faut savoir il
faut quand même savoir nager
même si on agit mais il faut savoir
nager et comment ça se passe les gens
viennent à l'école de voile de mandat
empreinte enfin le bout
planche alors pour l'instant on en
partie location
après on est c'est vrai c'est développer
selon la demande
des initiations et des balades sur le
tour de l'étang avec visite de la
réserve naturelle aussi et on propose
aussi d une autre activité qui j'espère
va marcher
qui est le paddle fitness et là à lire à
l'équilibré et la souplesse et la
souplesse et l'entretien physique à
l'image envoyait c'est donc la planche
on est tout seul mais ça se regarde le
moyen de le faire en groupe au salon
napoli sibilité de faire en groupe sont
à deux planches qui sont faites pour
huit personnes
donc ça soit adulte même dix ans en
dessus ces deux énormes paddle pas de
géant en fait c'est très sympa
coordonnées de la foi de coordonnées
général ça finit à lomé l'école de voile
s'est pas seulement deux pas de là c'est
la nouveauté mais il ya aussi de
nombreuses activités
les beaux jours par les beaux jours sont
revenus et la chaleur est revenue
sortant qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire dès ce week-end
alors ça y est nous on a commencé hier
donc location des canaux et des kayaks
des planches à voile du catamaran du
dériveur bien sûr donc tous ses étés
sont en location est aussi on a des
stages prévus sur les week-ends sur les
mercredis et en soirée certaines fois
pour toutes ces activités il est
conseillé de réserver ou de venir à
l'école de voile pour en louer pour la
location ne réserve pas on vient en
général il ya assez de matériel pour
tout le monde
y'a pas de temps d'attentes voilà et
c'est en plus du tarif d'entrée de lille
c'est à plus tard et je tenterai de
lille
merci beaucoup mais quel serveur d'aces
pour ceux qui voudraient tenter le
paddle votre équilibre
vous pouvez aller à l'école de voile on
reste à lille de loisirs mais cette fois
on va du côté de la réserve naturelle
puisque le samedi 7 mai elle ouvre ses
portes à tous les amoureux de la nature
l'occasion de découvrir la faune
protégée de la réserve et tout
particulièrement les oiseaux nicheurs
l'entrée libre de 8h30 à 13h30 écouter
joan enghelab garnier c'est la
conservatrice de la réserve pour moi
mais en fait c'est la saison des amours
c'est à dire qu'en fait les parades
encore mieux où ont déjà eu lieu les
mâles et femelles sont donc en cours les
nids sont formés voir on attend les
jeunes à voir il peut avoir des premiers
jeunes qui sont là qui va on peut voir
que les oiseaux nicheurs sur le site
donc on peut voir les grèves des grèbes
huppés les folkeux après la ya des beaux
passages de d'oiseaux migrateurs prévoir
des chevaliers et tu vas les gambettes
il peut y avoir je vais eu des mains qui
offraient de voir des différents oiseaux
qu'on appelle les limicoles qui vient
dans des cellules de migration on
continue notre cette ut week-end les
missions d'aidé dédié aux sorties et aux
loisirs avec la page cinéma cette
semaine bertrand pigné des yeux d'elsa
de saint-cyr-l'ecole vous invite à
découvrir très plenel
alors le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa cette semaine c'est un film
de john hillcoat un réalisateur
australien qui on doit la route ce
proposition' des hommes sans loi là il
nous arrive avec un film de gangsters
dans le atlanta d'aujourd'hui un film
très moderne très très dans le réel
d'aujourd'hui est un film qu'on compare
au heat de michael mann qui est quand
même probablement le must de ce qu'on a
pu faire en film de braquage
alors ce film nous raconte l'histoire de
deux groupes plus ou moins entremêlées
un groupe de braqueurs un groupe de
flics les flics ont introduit une taupe
chez les braqueurs mais en même temps
les braqueurs ont aussi des taupes chez
les flics
donc il ya comme ça une sorte de mélange
entre entre ces deux groupes
pas forcément très très simple à
comprendre mais en tout cas on entre
comme ça dans une dans une aventure
absolument folle qui dure deux heures
qui s'arrête absolument jamais on a
affaire à casey affleck un jeune type
plein de promesses woody harrelson un
vieux type toujours plein de promesses à
kate winslet qui est une très très
grande actrice ea games cadeau qu'on a
vu récemment dans le rôle de wonder
woman être plus de monstrueux le monstre
et rentrer à la maison la fin de la nuit
aucune limite à ce qu'un homme désespéré
peut faire quand il est piégé
ce film on le présente ici ce week end
en version française samedi à 18h15 en
version originale dimanche à 20h30 à des
tarifs toujours aussi accessible
j'espère que vous auriez la curiosité de
venir voir ce petit chef-d'oeuvre
à bientôt dans nos salles on poursuit
notre page cinéma avec vos avis sur les
sorties de la semaine camille lambert et
guillaume le squer sont allés à votre
rencontre
les dialogues sont formidables c'est à
la fois drôles ces mouvances à délivre
un message qui est évident sur la
différence c'est drôle c'est émouvant
non c'est bien c'est vraiment bien
c'était bien c'était romantique
voilà j'ai aimé qu'aux jeux l'état elle
a chanté et c'était très marrant et
triste
alors je les vois raided the gun j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment un film frais hyper
agréable
en plus c'est hugh jackman donc c'est un
effet fans et dense est vraiment drôle
j'ai passé un excellent moment vraiment
très bon pour les amateurs de métal
l'association met à soc de
voisins-le-bretonneux organise le
festival métal open ce faire deux jours
de concerts ça commence dès ce soir
vendredi 6 mai au café de la plage de
maurepas à 20 heures on écoute pierre
michel planchon il est le coordinateur
de l'association et ce sera suivi d'un
extrait de delhi l'inde et qui jouera à
la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux le samedi 7 mai
l'idée de proposer un événement voilà
assez marquant durant cette saison
autour de l'esthétique métal on voulait
une programmation plutôt éclectique dans
le genre voilà très ouverts d'où le open
c'est quand même le métal s'instille où
il ya plein de sous genres de pas mal de
choses donc on voulait que ce soit c'est
représentatif de nine et d'ouverture
voilà un peu fraternité entre les
différentes choses
c'est ça l'idée
c
avant de nous quitter un dernier
rendez-vous à destine à destination des
enfants dès l'âge de 10 ans la conteuse
praline gay para les invite à entrer
dans le petit théâtre ambulant du lieu
caravane rouge pour découvrir la mémoire
des lieux en regard d'un extrait
dépassement n'aura plus jamais le grand
silence d'avant c'était irréversible
et ça se passera au centre social du
pont du rotois à l'espace yves montand
et ses pralines gay para qui vont
recevoir pensez à réserver s'est
fortement conseillé le sais tu ce
week-end est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivi la semaine prochaine
c'est sephora namani qui elle vous
présentera des idées sorties et loisirs
moi de mon côté je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end